a huge part of cfar is to not only meet
but regularly talk with share ideas with
the true luminaries of my field
hi i'm young young zou i'm a political
scientist and i'm a cfar as really
global scholar cfr has really allowed me
to expand my global network in several
ways i get to belong to a research
program where i have direct access to
top senior scholars another way that
cfar has expanded my networks is through
the other global scholars many of them
are in the natural sciences and for
these people i you know i would never
really get to meet them naturally on my
own so it's been an amazing opportunity
through cfar to get to talk to them
regularly one
huge benefit of being a cfar global
scholar is getting this unrestricted
research funding what that means for me
is that i can pursue much more ambitious
projects it actually helps me to apply
for larger grants later on so it allows
me to prove to other funding agencies
that i can take on these large projects
because i already you know have done it
through all of the resources that cfar
provides the unrestricted funding access
to the senior scholars of my field in
related fields getting to meet all these
other peers in our global scholars
having professional development
workshops all of those resources put
together has just really amplified you
know our initial potential into
something much greater
[Music]
you